in New York State more than 10,000
people have died from the corona virus
in just a month most of them in New York
City our lead national correspondent
David Pegg know is there outside Mount
Sinai West hospital David good morning
so what's the latest on hospitalizations
in the New York City area well the
governor said that corona virus has not
overwhelmed the hospital systems here in
the state and that they have controlled
the spread but I'll tell you 2,000
people are still entering the hospitals
here in New York State every day with
corona virus symptoms the latest 24 hour
death toll was 671 New York's Governor
Andrew Cuomo provided the graph which
appears to show hospitalizations
statewide have plateaued and I believe
we now start on the path to normalcy if
we continue to be smart going forward
yesterday we told you that public health
officials in New York City are telling
medical providers to only test people
who are hospitalized with kovat symptoms
because the swabs that they use to
perform the tests are running low we
called the only u.s. manufacturer for
those swabs which is a company based in
Maine Puritan Medical Products you have
two shifts working ten hours each that's
20 hours a day six days a week
yes is that enough no but you you have
to you have to respect your employees
today the demand is greater than what we
can produce on a weekly basis more than
a thousand miles west of New York City
in Sioux Falls South Dakota coronavirus
has closed a pork processing plant and
that could affect the nation's meat
supply chain according to the company
CEO almost 300 people working at
Smithfield Foods tested positive for the
coronavirus South Dakota's governor is
resisting a stay at home order for Sioux
Falls even as the state's cases rose by
more than two hundred two days in a row
back in New York where the daily death
toll has been at or above 700 for most
of the last week I'm losing control
I'm getting everything done at the wire
Pat marmo is struggling to meet the
demand
he's a funeral director who owns six
Funeral Homes in New York City my phone
is ringing
probably like twice a minute he calls
himself one of the last responders when
his first started I was just pushing
social distancing as long as they stood
apart threw himself in the chapel I
would prepare that loved one we would do
a Colvin embalming we give it an open
casket
we even have a cosmetician cop and a
hairdresser now we don't have time for
that because we have another family
waiting to use that Chapel it's not
slowing up it seems like it's getting
worse it might just be me and I'm hoping
I'm wrong this is one time I want to be
wrong outside of one of Pat's funeral
home yesterday we met a woman who told
us she waited nearly 30 days to find a
funeral home who could receive her
sister's body and prepare it for burial
Tony David thank you very much